[Applause]
what the is these oh well sir we
have been experiencing an uptick in
reports of employee depression and
aggression so to address the issue we
implemented casual Friday where
employees can wear jeans once a month
well that was a catastrophic mistake
just look at that I mean how can someone
let the shame and dignity to come into
an office looking like that to put on
those clothes and stroll into a place of
business and think that that's an
acceptable way to live your life
probably shouldn't tell him our best
lawyer went insane and came in shirtless
today what is going on with those toes
second what is too long it should be
coming why would he subject us to this I
don't want to see another human beings
foot for the rest of the day Wow
this is definitely gonna be a traumatic
memory for me Alyssa Armstrong is going
to be here within the hour and she
represents glorious salvation ministries
the largest group of mega churches in
the country and this meeting was not
easy to get on oh no I had to buy three
of george w bush's dog paintings to get
him to vouch for me no we all know
there's no god but there is a ton of
money to be made in his name so let's
try to act like professionals today and
john put your glasses back on you look
like a prepubescent Voldemort thank you
sir
[Music]